it's only recently that kind of playing
the startup lottery black and butter
term has been be successful choice and
so for these I have a great grandparents
their attitude was they're gonna work
hard yeah my great-grandfather was a
factory worker in Argentina right and he
worked his ass off that my mother and
grandmother could be school teachers so
that mare mines I could go get you know
a PhD or an MD or whatever become a
professional and clearly it's not
necessarily happening but that was like
that was the the life plan for immigrant
families in this country for generations
was every generation one more level of
educational attainment which correlates
with one more level professional success
you know what recently happened a couple
totally and then so yeah yeah experience
cool you're now seventeen eighteen yeah
so yeah did the startup like 17 18 so I
go to college and went to NYU really
special program there called Gallatin
where you basically make up your own
major and so the whole school is it's
like build-a-bear universities I used to
joke about but it's really that you can
do any penance study you can do work
study you can do classes sort of like
hodgepodge this program together it's
cool and then while I was there was
helping run dorm room fun which is first
on capital's college university fund
it's a but a million dollar a year
actually might be more than that much
sure now but a million dollar your
vehicle just for investing it proceeded
for student founders
[Music]